[موسيقى]
يغادرون منازلهم الى البحر فجرا يقولون
اياما ولياليا في مهمه الحصول على قوتهم
ليس الحديثه نعم مشقه الابحار على الامواج
لسد الرماق اشد الما من قصص صيادين ذهبوا
للبحث عن قوه للاطفال من البحر دون ان
يعود اليهما
الحمد لله
وفي الصيادين قلت له داخل
عمرهم
هكذا اذا صارت السمكه في شواطئ الخوف فخا
للسياره فمن نجا من الموت بالالغام
الحوتيه يعود خائبا على خاربه ما يقتل
اسرته ليوم الواحد فقط
وان بدت عائمه للساعات في العمق فانها لا
تلتقط سوى القليل مما يطلبه سيدون من
البحر لضيقي مساحه الصياد
اما الان حيا الله تروح تجيب حقه اليوم
ماشي
بسبب تهديدات الالغام الحوتيه وتراجع
الانتاج السمك في الحديده والمخاء الى
قرابه النصف بحسب صيادين يلقيان بتاثيرته
سلبا على الحياه البعشيه للصيادين
والاقتصاد اليمني اجمالا على الاموال
حياتهم وهم يحاولون الحصول من البحر عما
يسدون مقاطفهم بلغم البحريه التي لوثت بها
الميليشات الحوثيه موانئ البلد وشواطها لم
يقتصر تاثيرها على الصيادين بل يمتد ايضا
ليهدد الملاحه الدوليه ال سعيد العربيه من
مدينه الخوخى جنوبيه الحديده